die klimaaktivisten greta teamwork die
können jetzt hier in berlin war ist
weiter auf tour jetzt war sie in mailand
und da ist etwas aufgefallen ganz genau
also es scheint immer offensichtlicher
zu werden das race for future die
internationale bewegung die geräte
thunberg ins leben gerufen hat ein
großes problem mit israel hat mit dem
jüdischen staat und da auch nicht
haltmacht vor durchaus radikalen
positionen
man sieht hier kreta thunberg mit einem
freund oder ihrem freund das ist noch
nicht ganz klar sie hat sich relativ
vertraut mit ihm gezeigt er lief mit ihr
in der ersten reihe hat also für fotos
mit posiert hat die bilder dieser demos
also mitgeprägt und was man da sieht was
um seinen hals was um seine schultern
hängt ist ein palästinensertuch aber
kein gewöhnliches kein mode accessoire
wie man es kennt sondern das ist
wirklich ein palästinensertuch für
fortgeschrittene israel hasser man sieht
auf der einen seite das typische muster
auf der anderen seite steht palestine
unten die aufschrift al kurz also das
ist der arabische begriff für jerusalem
muss palästina sein also muss israel
weggenommen werden israel muss aus
jerusalem vertrieben werden jerusalem
ist eigentlich die hauptstadt israels
versteht das parlament juden beten jeden
tag für jerusalem und dass das passt dem
jungen mann offenbar nicht und ich frage
mich ehrlich gesagt erstens was hat das
auf einer klima demo zu tun ist israel
das land mit 89 millionen einwohnern
jetzt der große klimasünder dass man
bekämpft nein natürlich nicht das
problem ist dass sich da ein gewisser
antisemitismus eingeschlichen hat das
bike ride ist ja das hat man schon im
sommer gesehen während des gaza krieges
als die hamas tausende raketen auf
israel gefeuert hat da hat freilich zur
future plötzlich angefangen zu twittern
und das in einer sprache die man
ansonsten wirklich nicht vermutet bei
einer klimabewegung da hieß es plötzlich
unsere herzen sind bei den märtyrern
dass islamistische sprache man hat sich
der offenbar infiltrieren lassen von
leuten die relativ gute sachen im sinn
haben und auf kreta selbst die er
wirklich einen wahnsinnigen einfluss hat
auf ganz viele junge menschen hat dinge
gewittert hat verbreitet von menschen
die israel boykottieren wollen die der
antisemitischen bds bewegung angehören
sie fand kein wort der solide ried mit
israelischen zivilisten und jetzt dass
man stellt so waßmann stellst du
jemanden mit so einem fall natürlich
nicht ganz nach vorne bei einer demo
wenn das nicht beabsichtigt ist das sind
ja pr-profis wenn man in kreta irgendwas
kann dann mobilisieren und für richtige
bilder sorgen und dass jetzt solche
symbole ganz vorne bei klima demos
gezeigt werden das macht mir sorgen
[Musik]